Bitte schön.
Vielen Dank.
Hallo Guten Tag, mein Name ist Kapagann. Ich bin hier zuständiger Assistenaristin Tethich.
Mit Ihnen würde ich gerne das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bevor wir über ihre aktuelle Becherung sprechen, möchte ich ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Okay. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Petra Westermann.
Petra Westermann.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Nachnamen stabilieren?
Ja. W-E-S-T-I-R-M-A-N-N.
Okay.
Herr Westermann.
Frau, Frau Petra.
Entschuldigung, ich habe Petra.
Ja, heute darf ich eine Frau sein.
Okay. Frau Petra Westermann. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin ja fast 44.
44.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 14.03.78.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin 83 Kilo.
80 Kilo?
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Westermann?
1,74 Meter.
Okay. Frau Westermann. Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, also mir ist etwas ganz Merkwürdiges passiert heute.
Heute Morgen.
Ich bin tatsächlich im Badezimmer umgefallen.
Mein Freund hat mich dann gefunden.
Ich bin irgendwie auf die Toilette gegangen.
Und habe wohl auch schlecht geschlafen,
weil ich so ein bisschen schlecht Luft bekommen habe.
Und dann bin ich ins Badezimmer gegangen.
Und da muss ich vor der Toilette umgefallen sein.
Und also ich weiß nichts mehr davon.
Ja.
Aber ich habe das dann gemerkt,
dass ich nass eine Wäsche anhatte.
Ich habe mich also eingenässt.
Aber ich wollte nur auf die Toilette gehen.
Stoßen Sie mit Ihrem Kopf?
Nein, ich glaube, ich habe keine Beule oder so.
Der Kopf tut nicht weh.
Nur das war so unheimlich,
dass ich einfach weggetreten bin.
Dass ich das gar nicht mitbekommen habe.
Okay.
Stoßen Sie?
Waren Sie bewusstlos?
Ja, ja, ja.
Wie lange dauert Ihre bewusstlos?
Pro, wie lange hat das gedauert?
Ich kann das gar nicht sagen.
Wahrscheinlich ein paar Minuten,
aber ich habe es nicht gesagt.
Ich habe es nicht gesagt.
Mein Freund hat dann gemerkt,
dass ich nicht wieder zurückkomme.
Und dann ist er gekommen.
Er hat mich aufgehoben.
Dann bin ich wieder aufgewacht.
Dann war mir so ein bisschen flau.
Ich habe es nicht gesagt.
Das ging so schnell.
Das Übliche, wenn man nachts aufzieht
und ein bisschen trahlich ist.
Aber offensichtlich ging es mir nicht gut.
Haben Sie sich auf zum gewissen?
Nein, zum Glück nicht.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass ich ein bisschen wie Husten habe.
Seit ein paar Tagen
tun mir die Beine auch weh.
Sind Sie auf bestimmte Seite hingefallen?
Nein, ich bin einfach nur so zusammengesagt.
Ich bin nicht auf die Seite gefallen.
Nein, ich bin nicht auf die Seite gefallen.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass ich nicht gut geschlafen habe.
Seit wann haben Sie nicht genug geschlafen?
Nein, das war nicht nur diese Nacht.
Ich war irgendwie unruhig.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass ich so einen komischen Husten habe.
dass ich nicht gut geschlafen habe.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass ich so einen komischen Husten habe.
Dass ich nicht so gut Luft bekommen kann.
Dann bin ich wohl aufgestanden.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Herzklopfen?
Nein, ich weiß nicht mehr, ob ich das vorher hatte.
Hatte ich Herzklopfen?
Nein, ich habe das Gefühl,
dass ich nicht gut Luft bekommen habe.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass ich nicht gut geflogen habe.
Hatte ich Herzklopfen?
Kann ich nicht mehr sagen,
ist mir nicht so aufgefallen.
Haben Sie Schwellungen
oder rötliche Farbe an der Haut?
Sie meinen jetzt,
wo ich hingefallen bin?
Nein, das ist alles gut gegangen.
Ich bin ja ganz gut gepolstert.
Ich wiege 83 kg.
Vielleicht habe ich irgendwo einen blauen Fleck, aber nicht schlimm.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Nein, eigentlich nicht mehr.
Nein, diese Luftnot ist ein bisschen unangenehm.
Hat Ihre Freund gesehen,
dass sie
eine kleine Luftfläche haben?
Nein, ich habe gesehen,
dass sie Gesetzen haben.
Das ich was habe?
Gesessen haben.
Gesessen, ja.
Ob ich Gesessen habe?
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Wie war denn das?
Ich habe es erst gesessen,
dann bin ich umgekippt.
Wie sind Sie momentan?
Fühlen Sie sich gut?
Nein, gut, würde ich nicht sagen.
Wir kontrollieren jetzt
Ihre Sauerstoffsetigung.
Wir schreiben,
wir werden Elektrokardiografie geschrieben.
Wir kontrollieren mit dem Gerät
Ihre Ihr Herz.
Ja, bitte schön.
Gut, das machen wir jetzt, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie früher eine Schäfte?
Nein, so, das habe ich tatsächlich noch nie gehabt.
Ich dachte, so etwas kriegt man irgendwie mit 80,
dass man immer noch die Schäfte hat.
dass man im Badezimmer unmächtig wird.
Aber ja, ich habe das noch nie gehabt.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber?
Also ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen, ich fühle mich jedenfalls nicht fieberig.
Nein.
Leiden Sie unter Schüttelprost oder Nachtschweiß?
Leiden Sie unter Lehmung?
Oder Sprachstörung?
Ach so.
Ne, also ich kann alles fühlen
und kann auch alles bewegen.
Und habe auch keine Sprachstörung, nein.
Wir haben gesagt,
dass Sie husten.
Seit wann haben husten Sie?
Das ist erst neu.
Ja, erst habe ich gedacht, das kommt vielleicht noch.
Was weiß ich, also nachdem vom Urlaub,
wir waren in der Sonne.
Und als wir dann zurückgeflogen sind,
es war ein langer Flug.
Es war ein langer Flug.
Haben Sie trocken oder?
Das ist eher so dieses Gefühl,
dass ich eher trocken rufen.
Haben Sie Atemot?
Ja, ja.
Seit wann haben Sie?
Ja, das ist neu.
Seit heute Nacht, würde ich sagen.
Ja, seit heute Nacht.
Sie haben gesagt,
dass Sie im Urlaub
manche Auslands waren.
Wir waren in Thailand.
Das war natürlich ein sehr langer Rückflug.
Ja.
Da ist es mir vor Ort,
ist es mir schlecht gegangen.
Da habe ich mal ein paar Tage wirklich flachgelegen,
weil ich mich bei Durchfall hatte.
Da ist irgendwas mit dem Essen oder mit dem Wasser nicht in Ordnung gewesen.
Und da ist es mir ein bisschen schlecht gegangen.
Wann sind Sie von Thailand zurück?
Das ist ungefähr 10 Tage her.
10 Tage.
Sie haben gesagt, durchschwahl.
Seit wann haben Sie durchschwahl?
Das war nur da, als ich im Urlaub war.
Ja, das war nur im Urlaub.
Dann habe ich jetzt gedacht, das ist alles gut.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasser lassen?
Nein, normalerweise nicht.
Haben Sie in der Lexuszeit
ungewollt ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, leider nicht abgenommen.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ist es gut.
Heute geht es nicht so gut,
aber normalerweise ist es gut.
Sie haben gestern Abend nicht genug geschlafen.
Leider Sie unter Stress?
Normalerweise eigentlich nicht.
Haben Sie bemerkt,
haben Sie Ihre Beine angeschwollt?
Nein, normalerweise nicht.
Haben Sie Ihre Beine angeschwollt?
Nein, geschwollt.
Ich habe in der einen Wade
ein bisschen Druckgefühl.
In der rechten Wade.
Das habe ich aber nicht so ernst genommen.
Ob das geschwollt ist,
ich habe immer mal ein bisschen geschwollte Beine.
Besonders ist, weiß ich nicht.
Wann haben Sie bemerkt?
Das ist schon ein paar Tage.
Ich habe gedacht, dass es von alleine gekommen ist,
dann geht es wieder weg.
Wie ist Ihre Regelblutung?
Ich nehme die Pille.
Nehmen Sie Pille ein.
Seit wann nehmen Sie Pille ein?
Schon ewig lange.
Seit ich 20 bin.
20 Jahre.
Wenn Sie haben, haben Sie es.
Frau Westermann,
Leiden Sie unter chronischer Erkrankungen?
Ich habe tatsächlich eine Endometriose.
Das heißt, ich habe also immer,
zur Periode habe ich immer eine Endometriose.
Aber sonst bin ich eigentlich fit und gesund.
Wo ist Sie schon einmal operiert?
Als Kind habe ich die Mandeln rausbekommen.
Mit 18 hatte ich dann noch eine Blindarmopil.
Haben Sie bestimmte Allergie?
Ich habe die
bestimmte Allergie gegen etwas Medikamente.
Das Einzige, was ich weiß,
wo ich darauf reagiere, ist braunes Pflaster.
Wie sieht Ihr Allergie aus?
Wenn ich braunes Pflaster getragen habe,
dann kriege ich halt so rote Pünktchen da
und das Juckt.
Wenn ich das immer noch drauf lasse,
dann geht irgendwann die Haut auf.
Das sieht dann nicht gut aus.
Haben Sie alle Grundimpfungen erhalten?
Ja, für diese Teilandreise braucht ich ja auch alle Impfungen.
Und natürlich bin ich auch gegen Corona geimpft.
Okay, Frau Westermann.
Ich möchte für Sie zusammenfassen.
Und für mich auch.
Sie haben eine
Zeit, ein paar Tage
Gusten.
Und seit einigen Tagen leiden Sie unter Atemnot.
Das ist erst ganz akut mit der Atemnot.
Das ist erst seit gestern.
Gestern.
Nach der Urlaub
haben Sie
alle Symptome gesehen.
Und
für ein paar Tage haben Sie
in der rechten Wad
Schwellung.
Angeschwellung.
Nee, eigentlich mehr so ein Druckgefühl in der Wad.
Dass das geschwollen ist, ist mir gar nicht so aufgefallen.
Ich möchte mal gucken, ob das geschwollen ist.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ihr Gusten ist trocken.
Angeschwärten hatten Sie früher nicht.
Gestern Abend
könnten Sie nicht gut schlafen.
Heute Morgen
stürzen Sie
in der Wadeszimmer.
Ich bin nicht nur gestürzt,
sondern ich war unmächtig.
Und Sie waren nicht bewusstlos.
Doch, ich war bewusstlos.
Unmächtig ist bewusstlos.
Sie haben momentan keine Schmerzen.
Nee, also vom Sturz oder so habe ich keine Schmerzen.
Nein.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, seit 20 Jahren rauche ich
so ein halbes Päckchen am Tag.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nur am Wochenende trinke ich mal so 2 Gläser Wein.
Okay.
Diese Frage ist nicht persönlich,
sondern medizinische Fragen.
Sie sind trocken?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich muss noch arbeiten.
Leben Sie ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, ja, ja, die leben beide noch.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie
Kröncherkrankungen?
Meine Mutter
hat ein Morbus Kron.
Aber sonst
andere chronische Erkrankungen gibt es eigentlich nicht.
Ihr habt ihr gesund?
Ja, der ist gesund.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich habe keine Geschwister.
Wie ist es für Sie?
Nein, ich bin ledig, aber ich lebe mit meinen Partner zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, keine Kinder.
Okay.
Wo ist Ihr Beruf?
Ich bin Büroangestellte.
Okay.
Im Thailand hatten Sie Duschwahl?
Ja, und zwar heftig, ja, naja.
Wie lange dauert Ihre Duschwahl?
Das hat mich 2 Urlaubstage gekostet, ja.
2 Tage.
Ist das flüssig?
Ja, da ist alles nur so rausgelaufen.
Ich hatte ordentlich Bauchtrempfe.
Und dann ist alles unverdaut rausgekommen.
Haben Sie im Stuhlgang Blut bemerkt?
Nein, das war nur Durchfall.
Irgendwie.
Das war nur Durchfall.
Nein, das war nur Durchfall.
Irgendwie verkehrtes Essen gehe ich mal davon aus.
Ich habe wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Sie haben ja so viel gefragt.
Ja, jetzt möchte ich nur eigentlich,
dass das nicht normal passiert.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen erschreckend,
wenn man umfällt.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Erinnern Sie vor dem Sturz?
Nein, der kann ich mich nicht gut daran erinnern.
Ich weiß doch, ich wollte auf die Toilette gehen.
Und im Badezimmer muss ich dann umgefallen sein.
Ich sehe noch nicht schwindelig momentan.
Im Augenblick nicht mehr, ne, ne, ne.
Okay.
Frau Westermann,
Sie haben ja schon gesagt,
Frau Westermann, zuerst untersuche ich Sie körperlich.
Und dann kontrollieren wir Ihre Blut.
Und Ihre Blutgastanalyse veranlassen ich.
Was kann man an der Blutgastanalyse sehen?
Wir kontrollieren in Ihrem Blut Ihre Sauerstoffsetigung.
Und bestimmte Minerelle, Kalium, Natrium,
Kohleinhydrat, so ich nervöse, kontrollieren wir.
Und gegebenenfalls veranlassen ich für Sie
Schädeltomographie.
Braucht man dafür, ist das eine Strahlenbelastung?
Bei der Schädeltomographie?
Ja, Schädeltomographie hat Strahlenbelastung eigentlich.
Nach Ihrer körperlichen Untersuchung entscheiden wir uns,
ob wir Schädeltomographie durchführen.
Und wir müssen das nicht machen.
Gut, dann bin ich gespannt, wie es weitergeht.
Gut, jetzt gibt es noch Fragen.
Ein paar Anregungen kamen ja unterwegs.
Aber jetzt scheinen alle ganz zufrieden zu sein.
Hat keiner meine Frage?
Ja, im Chat eigentlich.
Keiner, was?
Beim Husten hatten Sie Blutung?
Nein, keine Blut beim Husten.
Trockener Husten und eher Luftnot als Husten.
Nein, abgenommen habe ich auch nicht.
Hat sie aber auch gefragt?
Und da habe ich gesagt, leider nicht.
Ich habe nicht gefragt, ob ich sie nicht mehr habe.
Ach so, gute Frage.
Nein, gab es nicht.
Haben Sie gekrampft?
Nein, gekrampft habe ich wohl nicht.
Ich habe nicht gefragt, ob ich sie nicht mehr habe.
Nein, nichts in der Richtung.
Ich habe nicht klug beschweren.
Klug beschweren?
Kluggefühl? Nein, nein, nein.
Noch eine Frage.
Haben Sie Fieber und
an der Wärmung von den Beinen,
die Beine, die haben gesagt,
Beine schmerzen, wenn ich nicht.
Ja, sie hat gesagt, Drucken fühle im Bein.
Sie hat das irgendwie ein bisschen weggesteckt,
nachdem Otto Joa hat ein bisschen weh getan.
Hat das aber nicht besonders beschrieben.
Hat auch nichts von Überwärmung erzählt.
Also wenn Sie anfassen oder Drucken,
mehr Schmerzen, haben Sie etwas zu bemerken?
Ja, Sie hat das nicht beschrieben.
Das wäre quasi jetzt ein Ergebnis der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Aber es ist definitiv im Fall nicht beschrieben.
Aber so wie Sie fragen, natürlich, klar,
hat sie Schmerzen im Bein.
Alles klar.
Ja, zumindest ja.
Haben Sie leicht blaue Flecken?
Im Sinne von Lip-Ödem?
Das ist ja eine interessante Frage.
Die Frage habe ich schon ewig nicht mehr gehört.
Kennt jemand das Phänomen des Lip-Ödem?
Die Patienten kriegen tatsächlich unheimlich leicht blaue Flecken.
Die müssen nur scharf angeguckt werden.
Dann haben die blaue Flecken.
Aber ich habe auch keine Blutverdünnung.
Keine blaue Flecken.
Können wir?
Sie haben im Mikro noch aus.
Ja.
So viele Symptome, aber ich würde mehr.
Wir gucken mal.
Eigentlich habe ich eine ziemlich breite Spur gelegt.
Aber wir schauen dann.
Guten Tag Frau Oberarsten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit?
Ja, ich habe gesehen, Sie haben eine Patientin aufgenommen.
Ja, in der Notaufnahme haben wir neue Patienten.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Frau Petra Westermann.
Frau Westermann hat sich bei uns wegen heute Morgen stürzen.
Heute Morgen bewusstlos und nachdem stürzen bewusstlos,
bewusstlos sein zu sein vor.
Sie haben seit gestern Abend noch nicht.
Sie haben seit gestern trockenen Haber.
Frau Westermann war vor zehn Tagen im Thailand zurückgekommen.
Sie ist aus Thailand zurückgekommen.
Sie ist heute Urlaub zurückgekommen.
Sie sei aus Thailand zurückgekommen.
Sie hat zwei Tage durchgefahren.
Sie war sehr flüssig.
Nach zwei Tagen hat sie ihre Tür selbst begrenzt.
Sie hat nur zwei Tage gedauert.
Sie hat irgendwas verkehrtes gegessen.
Frau Westermann hat für ein paar Tage in Iran rechten.
Sie hat zwei Tage gedauert.
Sie hat keine Schmerzen,
Kapitalissa k不管.
Sie hatrospective Schmerzen,
Erkrankungen leiden sie an endometriosis.
Als die Kind war, sei Tonsiloktomie erfolgt und vor 35 Jahren, sei Aponeoktomie
durchgeführt worden. Sie haben Brownes-Flaster-Allergie.
Allergie gegen Brownes-Flaster, ja.
Sie sei vollständig geimpft. Sie raut seit 20 Jahren jedes Tag, okay, ein
Pektion pro Tag. Sie trinken gelegentliche Alkohol, nur
am Wochenende eins oder zwei Glas der Wein. Drogenkonsum wurde
verneint und in Familienanamnese leider seine Mutter an
morbispron. Sie haben keine Geschwister und Kinder. Sie leben im
Wohnen mit ihrer Partner und sie sei Büroangestellte.
Gut, was ist denn jetzt Ihre Vermutung? Was fehlt der denn?
Die an annästische Angaben deuten am Hessens auf Tia hin.
Okay. Und was wäre alternativ, möglichst differenzial diagnostisch?
Sie ist so lange Reise gefallen.
Sie hat eine lange Reise gemacht.
Deswegen denken wir auf, ich vergesse mal, wenn es
der Faculus-Krankheiten. Ja, Trombose, ne?
Ja, tief auf die Beine.
Und was noch mit der Luftnot?
Und Pulmonalembulé. Ja, genau.
Und was könnte es schlimmstenfalls noch sein? Aber eigentlich
hat sie das nicht so beschrieben, wenn sie jetzt so zusammen
gebrochen ist und was könnte es unter Umständen noch sein?
Wenn sie vom Kopf her denken, dass es keine Tia ist.
Okay, Apoplexe. Das wäre ja wie Tia, ne?
Transitorisch iti-ischemische Attacke.
Wenn sie sich jetzt auf die Zunge gebissen hätte, was wäre
dann wahrscheinlich? Hier ein Timur, aber ich färme
mit dem nicht.
Hier eine Belötung.
Apelipsi wäre vielleicht noch eine Variante, ne?
Dass sie praktisch den ersten Krampf, aber sie hat ja nicht
beschrieben, dass sie gekrampft hat und ihr Freund hat
es auch nicht beschrieben. Also es ist hier nur bei den
differenzial Diagnosen.
Vielleicht kann ich Muskosucken auch fragen.
Ja, aber die Frage ist ja eigentlich in jeder Hinsicht
verneint worden, ne?
Gut, ja, was machen Sie denn jetzt, um dahinter zu kommen,
was der guten Frau fehlt?
Ja, nach EKG und Blutgasanalyse Ergebnisse können wir
manche Diagnose ausschließen.
Nämlich?
Nämlich, ja.
Und ja, zuerst denken wir Tia.
Es ist wichtig und Pulmonarambuli auch wichtig, deswegen
Toraxiitifaranasenvia und MRT auch denken wir.
Ja, genau.
Und bei der körperlichen Untersuchung, worauf gucken Sie da?
Ja.
Muskulstarkung sind Sie gleich oder nicht?
Ja, okay, also ja.
Ob es einen Seitenunterschied gibt, ja.
Ja, werde und ob es schenkt, kontrollieren wir,
sind Sie gleiche Messung haben?
Ah, die Umfangsmaße.
Ja, die Umfangsmaße, ob die gleich sind, ja.
Ja, ja, genau.
Kontrollieren wir.
Vom Oberschenkel und vielleicht auch vom Unterschenkel, ne?
Ja, ja.
Vom Femoralis, Puls und Vistales Puls auch kontrollieren wir.
Kleinstgehirn-Tests vielleicht können wir durchschließen.
Ja, neurologische Tests, aber würden Sie denn vielleicht noch
eine operative Untersuchung machen?
Eine, im Rahmen der körperlichen Untersuchung,
eine relativ einfache körper, eine einfache operative Untersuchung?
Ja, EKG und Ultraschall.
Ja, was, was schallen Sie denn?
Duplex-Ustrachall, sagen wir nicht.
Ja, was schallen Sie?
Ah, okay.
Wir können durch Ultraschall, duplex-Ustrachall,
TFT und Arterelle Verschuluskrankheiten können wir.
Ja, also genau.
Wir machen duplex-Sono der Beine, ja.
Also einmal durch die Umfangsmessung gucken wir nach dem Bein
und durch die duplex-Sono-Graphie
gucken wir, ob wir da die Thrombose finden.
Thrombose, die Tissue.
Ja, gut.
Gut, wenn sich jetzt tatsächlich bestätigt,
dass diese Patientin eine TFT und eine Lungenartilienimpulierung hat.
Was ist denn dann die Therapie?
0,6 Milliliter Klextan geben wir oder, ja,
Hyperlinisation, Hyperlinisierung, ja.
Wenn wir Blutung irgendwo nicht,
Also gucken wir erst, ob wir die Hirnblutung sind.
Ja, und dann,
wenn wir sicher sind, dass es keine Hirnblutung ist
oder sonstige Blutung.
Und dann können wir Hyperlinisation,
ja, können wir Hyperlinisierung, ja.
Und was braucht sie dafür?
Wenn wir TFT-Diagnose zischa zint,
können wir Klassifikation,
oder können wir Klassifieren.
Können wir was?
Klassifikation.
Ach, klassifizieren, ja, jetzt habe ich es verstanden.
Ja, klassifizieren.
Und wenn es, wenn Trombose nicht viel ist,
können wir mit Strumfe,
Koopression, Strumfe, ja.
Koopression, Strumfe und Gehtraining zu Hause entpassen.
Ja, aber wenn wir jetzt von der Lungmaschärikämbulie ausgehen,
was braucht sie denn, wenn sie jetzt,
Was ist dann?
Wenn es groß ist,
für mich,
ich weiß, ich weiß,
doch bei der Lungmaschärikämbulie.
Was braucht sie denn,
wenn wir die jetzt hochgradig Hyperlinisieren wollen?
Was braucht sie?
Wie geben Sie ihr denn das Hyperlin?
Zugang legen.
Ja, genau, die brauchen Zugang, ja, klar.
Wir haben Nationalanaufnahme
und Zugang und natürlich 100%
Oxygen-Sauerkauf geben.
Gut, und die kriegt also für die Lungen,
für die Lungen, althin,
und wie kriegt sie erstmal Hyperlin im Bolus,
kriegt ein Schuss vorweg
und dann kriegt sie eine Dauernfusion
über 6 Tage, einige Tage.
6 Tage geben wir.
Gut, und danach,
das kriegt sie anschließend?
Wir haben gesagt, Klexane?
Ja.
Oder Markumar, also Umstellung,
praktisch dann auf ein Orales...
Ja, wenn wir sie zu Hause entlassen,
schreiben wir
Kumadin oder...
Genau.
Oder ein anderes zugelassenes
Trombosemedikament, ne?
Gut, okay.
Und ja, Sie haben gesagt,
Sie soll wegen der TVT
Kompressionsstrümpfe tragen.
Bis wohin sollen die Strümpfe gehen?
Ja, bis lange Zeit tragt sie.
Nee, ich meine, diese Frage war nicht,
wie lange sie tragen soll,
sondern wie lange die Strümpfe sein sollen.
Bis zum Knie oder bis oben?
Bis zur Leiste.
Je nach der Lokalisation.
Nee, bis oben.
Ja.
Auf alle Fälle bis oben.
Und wie lange soll sie sie tragen?
Ja, sie hat...
Sie hat eine Risikofaktion,
so lange es seit Pille nimmt.
Zuerst stoppen wir Pille.
Nee, ich wollte jetzt erst mal hören,
wie lange soll sie ihre Strümpfe tragen?
Ja, ich denke, 6 Monate.
Ja, eben, genau, 6 Monate.
Und nach 6 Monaten, bevor wir die Strümpfe weglassen,
müssen wir noch mal ein Duplex machen,
noch mal gucken, ob der Trombus weg ist.
Ja, und dann, wie lange muss sie denn ihr Markum wahrnehmen?
Einem Jahr.
Ja, eigentlich auch 6 Monate,
und da muss man gucken, wie der Trombus aussieht.
Mindestens 6 Monate.
Ja, und dann muss man gucken,
wie der Trombus aussieht.
Mindestens 6 Monate.
Und bei Bedarf eben länger.
Und dann würde man auch natürlich noch länger den Strumpf tragen.
Und jetzt gehen wir mal davon aus,
diese Frau will weiterhin die Pille nehmen
und wird auch das Rauchen nicht aufgeben.
Ja, klar.
Wenn die im übernächsten Jahr wieder nach Thailand fliegen will.
Oder sonst wohin?
Ja, vor dem Urlaub raten wir,
Sie raten wir ihr Erstkontroll.
Eine erstliche Kontrolle, ja?
Ja, und im Flugzeug
dürfen wir nicht schon lange Zeit sitzen.
Ja, muss man aber ja nun.
Muss man ja, aber was soll sie deshalb machen,
wenn sie in den Flieger geht?
Sie soll ihre guten Alkompressionsstrumpfe rausholen.
Sie soll die Kompressionsstrumpfe tragen,
für den Flieger.
Wenn sie Markuma oder andere Medikamente nicht nimmt ein,
können wir wieder diese Medikamente geben.
Ja, man kann also kurz vor der Reise tatsächlich,
kann man hier eine Thrombose-Profilaxe geben, genau.
Das kann sie sich auch selber geben.
Kann sie auch mitnehmen für den Rückflug.
Und sie soll eben ihre Strumpfe anziehen für den Flug.
Ja, das vergessen tatsächlich auch viele Patienten,
wenn sie mal eine Thrombose hatten,
dass sie dann beim nächsten Mal,
vielleicht mal die Strumpfe wieder anziehen.
Ja, okay, gut.
Gut, das waren die Sachen, die ich dazu sagen hätte.
Dann sind wir mal gespannt,
dass bei den Untersuchungen unserer Patientin rauskommt.
Ach so, was wir noch nicht besprochen haben.
Was wollen Sie denn im Blut untersuchen?
Im Blut untersuchen.
Zuerst kontrollieren wir Zauberstoffsetigung.
Zauberstoffsetigung für Tefateur.
Ja, genau.
Das war eigentlich schon die wichtigste Sache.
Blutbild, Delimia.
Gut, dann haben wir wirklich alles.
Aber genau, Sie haben schön die Risikofaktoren rausgearbeitet.
Also sie raucht, sie nimmt die Pille.
Und dann sollte man auch nicht vergessen,
dass sie sich dann noch mal auf die Brille schmacken.
Vor dem Rückflug hat sie diese Durchfallepisode gehabt.
Das heißt, sie war eben möglicherweise auch exikiert.
Und hat damit also nochmal ihren Blutfluss
nochmal ein bisschen runtergefahren.
Weil sie vielleicht nicht genug getrunken hat.
Kann man zumindest annehmen,
dass sie 3 Tage lang auf der Toilette sitzt und Durchfall hat.
Dass der nicht genug trinkt.
Und damit hat sie also quasi schon 3 Risikofaktoren.
Und dazu die Reiseanamese.
Damit ist sie natürlich hoch,
hoch, Trombose gefährdet.
Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist in diesem Fall extrem groß.
Okay.
Gut.
Ich überlege gerade irgendwas,
das war mir auch.
Ja, sie raucht tatsächlich keine ganze Packung am Tag,
sondern nur eine halbe.
Aber ansonsten war alles richtig wiedergegeben.
Ja, ich habe schon bewusstlos geschrieben,
aber wenn ich zusammenfasse,
manchmal vergesse ich das.
Ja, ich glaube, irgendwas hat sie auf die falsche Richtung gebracht.
Dass sie nicht zuerst an die Lungenemolie gedacht haben.
Sie hat das ja auch mit dem Bein tatsächlich so ein bisschen
so am Rande nur erwähnt.
Und insofern war das irgendwie schon,
dass man erstmal an den Kopf denkt.
Aber tatsächlich war es eben eigentlich die Beine,
die dann zur Lungenemolie geführt haben.
Gut.
Für alle Nordrhein-Westfalen,
das war ein bekannter Düsseldorferfall.
Ja.
Gut.
Ja, möchte irgendjemand von den Kollegen noch etwas zu diesem Fall
sagen, zur Präsentation oder zur Vollständigkeit?
Haben Sie Raten?
Das kann ja ein paar Nachfragen,
die nochmal die Spur verschärft haben.
Ja, wann haben Sie Prüfungen?
5. Dritte.
5. Dritte?
Ja.
Ui, das ist sozusagen übermorgen.
Ja, übermorgen.
Ja.
Gut.
Ich hoffe mal, Sie haben einen Fall, der ein bisschen eindeutiger ist
und wo Sie sich nicht in die irre leiten lassen.
Ich glaube, sprachlich ist es eigentlich kein Problem.
Und das ist die eigentliche Frage.
Darum geht es ja, um die Sprache.
Sie prüfen ja nicht Ihre Diagnosen.
Ich glaube, es geht um die Sprache.
Und vielleicht machen Sie überlegen.
Also, ich glaube, so kann es laufen.
Dann halten wir mal die Daumen für übermorgen.
Okay.
Dr. Günis.
Ich denke, es war sehr gut.
Also klar.
Sollen wir Dienstag wieder treffen oder ist vorher noch was gefordert?
Dienstag.
Dienstag wieder? Okay.
Wann sollen wir am Dienstag schreiben?
Wie immer 20 Uhr.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Dienstag, Donnerstag, immer 20 Uhr.
Okay.
Wir müssen ein Stückchen Stabilität haben.
Wenn bei mir irgendwas unerwartet dazwischenkommt, melde ich mich.
Aber ich würde davon ausgehen, dass wir uns auf alle Fälle Dienstag 20 Uhr treffen können.
Okay.
Vielen Dank.
Dann sage ich allen Tschüss.
Schönen Abend.
Jetzt kann man schon wieder gutes Wochenende sagen.
Ich hoffe, dass am Dienstag die Welt noch steht.
Und dass wir uns ohne große Sorgen treffen können.
Ja, alles klar.
Und natürlich für Sie, Frau Dr. Carvergan.
Toi, toi, toi für die Prüfung.
Und viel Erfolg.
Vielen Dank.
Ich vermute, werden wir wieder, werden wir uns wieder...